an outstanding coach at North Dakota
State and now the head coach at Wyoming
and got the honor to coach Carson Wentz
and also Josh Allen not a bad combo
platter
I'm sure you've uh been busy this week
people talking to you about the former
quarterback certainly Josh Allen thanks
for joining us coach how are you you
know what really doing well Dan you know
it was a pleasure to have an opportunity
to work with Carson Wentz when he was
younger and now Josh Allen and if I had
a quarter for every time somebody asked
me to compare the two I see a wealthy
guy but you know what there there there
there there's tons of similarities
between the two guys and and I
understand the conjecture of you know
the different quarterbacks that are out
there and how they're slotted and what
organization is isn't looking at a
certain guy and and quite frankly with
the general managers that I've had a
chance to talk with have been very
transparent with where I see Josh at
right now obviously the film you know
has some great things to say but they're
always interested on what's the other
side that we don't see on Josh Allen and
hey you know what what kind of things
can you tell us about him to project
success okay the first time you saw
Carson Wentz when's the first time you
were impressed with Carson Wentz well
you know what's interesting he was a he
was a skinny redheaded freckled kid the
space between his tooth and he didn't
even play quarterback when he was a
junior in high school and so he shows up
at fall camp and our offense is a
complicated offense it's you know Pat
Shermer came in and put it all in at
NDSU many years ago and so Carson was
out there his first scrimmage and a lot
of different variables a playlist and
call which is pretty long and he comes
up to the line we were down in the red
zone and he stepped back and I did not
know what he was doing he stepped back
change the protection change the running
through a slant to the X on the weak
side and I'm like what are you doing he
goes well coach you know what I saw I
saw there was a straight man the corner
was outside position so I changed the
protection hit the slant on the X and I
went wow most of these guys when they're
freshmen are having a
they've got a squeaky voice they can't
even know what the snap count is and so
he's off the chart as far as his mental
capabilities and you know his character
is outstanding and you know we had a
long talk with the Eagles because they
were saying you know he didn't even
start for you when you when he was
younger why are we gonna invest all this
you know draft picks and everything else
and when I said don't undersell his
competitive nature and his competency
and you know and I think that's that's
been bare doubt you know it's gonna see
it's gonna be great for us to watch Josh
as he excels in the NFL also what are
GM's asking you that
then I'm not and like you you're gonna
be transparent with them I guess but you
want to protect
Josh Allen as well like you want to
support your guys so how do you kind of
walk that fine line there well you know
many of these guys have been friends for
years and years and years and you know
the best thing you can do is when you're
establishing credibility is being
transparent and you know while we're
appreciating and not so much protecting
Josh but the film doesn't lie Josh can
do some unbelievable things I mean
there's no one else that I've seen
through 35 years of coaching that can
expose defenses in different parts of
the field because of his arm strengthen
is his ability to extend place you know
a couple things they really want to know
is what does the work habits like what
kind of competency does he have what is
mental capabilities how has he
progressed into your system and then the
other thing that you know the
million-dollar question and I understand
numbers are they're you know they look
at the completion percentage and if you
just look at your numbers you go okay
there's there's there's a red flag here
it's much you know it's debated but why
are those numbers where they are and can
we change those numbers you know that
you know to play in the NFL I think
quarterbacking in the NFL is the hardest
thing in all sports and the windows that
Josh is going to be throwing into you
know are going to be tighter window so
what he's confronted with and so why why
was the number where it was and what are
some
things that are going to predict his
huge upside and so you know it's been
some great conversations it'll be
interesting to see you know where he
goes and and on what pic he goes if you
were Cleveland what would you do what
would you do I take him this is what I
have seen is you know during the course
of the fall people may not recognize
Josh is young and he really had an
opportunity to to come out last year but
he's young and I've seen you know
tremendous progress for him even
throughout this year and you know so
some of the questions that you have is
saying can this guy be the face of the
franchise can this guy have the ability
can he step under Center and you know
walk in and lead a locker room full of
guys offensive linemen or 30-some years
old and have three kids and their lives
are on their professional lives online
and everything else and so there's no
doubt I've seen tremendous improvement
in Josh I saw it even when he came back
and played in our bowl game and then
when he came back from the from the
Senior Bowl and then he did our pro day
here you know the little things that I
see him cleaning up his footwork and an
opportunity to work you know with a
strict quarterback guru as far as these
finer tune things that's going to help
him with those completion percentages he
can I know this he can you can clean
that up which you can't clean up is
somebody who can run sideways and throw
a dart in the back of the endzone odd
John Elway you can't cover that and so
that's why I'd say his value system
strong he's going to be able to be
resilient he plays in cold weather he
overcame adversity this year we had a
lot of players that won in the NFL the
previous year now one time did he come
in my office and complain about the the
weapons that he lost and he even told me
goes you know coach if I get drafted
where I think I'm gonna draft and I'm
probably gonna go in to rebuild and so
I've got to learn how to work through
adversity those are qualities that you
cannot just teach those are intrinsic
things that he asked if Carson Wentz and
Josh Allen were in the Octagon who's
your money on
I'm not gonna go1 I'm not going to touch
that one they'll get winners all right
okay I understand your position though
but you know what there I would say this
every says well what's the comparison I
had a chance to coach against Peyton
Manning in college and you know my
assessment I'm a defensive guy my
assessment was Carson has tons of
qualities they're very much like Peyton
Manning I would say while I never
coached against Brett Favre you got a
far with Josh and that's a double-edged
sword but if you corral it right Brett
Favre's pretty good quarterback - how
far is the farthest you've seen Josh
Allen throw football I like 80 some
yards we needed to swing it we need
exact because we had the over-under at
82 well I was gonna say 82 but I thought
somebody think I was just making it up I
I think he can throw it I think you can
throw it farther in 86 82 yards I do he
I you know out of high school we saw
music he's a high school baseball
pitcher could throw 90 some mile an hour
fastball but he was you know he was 6
foot 3 100 or 200 pounds now he's six
foot five and he's 240 pounds and so he
can wing it if I had one of my guys
stand in front of him 20 yards out could
he actually kill them could he stop
their heart if he yes on the field
and everybody sees balls thrown yeah you
can hear his ball you can hear it you
can hear it and I never experienced that
before and so you know that's probably
probably the best way to describe how he
can throw it I mean he he can throw it
on a rope and he can expose areas of the
field that defensive coaches typically
don't have to cover because no one can
expose them he can so take that
completion percentage you'll hone that
down
but take that completion percentage out
there and I hear all the pundits he's
gonna put places the ball places that no
one else can hit and that's a tough act
to cover Thank You coach love the
uniforms we appreciate you joining us
you bet Craig Bohl that's Wyoming head
football coach Continental Tire coach
corner Continental Tire proud supporter
the Dan Patrick show all the tires that
you need no matter what you're doing
they got the new terrain contact eighty
the ideal all-terrain tire check it out
it's great for SUVs you get the details
at Continental Tire dot-com content
entire Coaches Corner for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]